herzlich willkommen zur folge 196 des
faz einspruch podcast des wöchentlichen
podcast der faz für recht justiz und
politik heute kommt eine besondere folge
nämlich zur impfpflicht wir senden aus
frankfurt heute mein name ist reinhard
müller ich bin verantwortlich für
zeitgeschichte staat und recht und eben
faz einspruch und bei mir im studio ist
stephan klenner stephan klär ist seit
dezember neuer reaktor im team von faz
einspruch auf welche weise nähern wir
uns dem thema heute kleiner auf ganz
unterschiedliche weise uns ist vor allem
wichtig die unterschiedlichen
standpunkte die es so zu impfpflicht
gibt zusammenzuführen und zunächst
sprechen sie ja mit volker bouffier
das ist zum thema unterschiedliche
standpunkte auf jeden fall ein ganz
guter gesprächspartner weiß ja auch
innerhalb der union ganz
unterschiedliche standpunkte zu
impfpflicht gibt und damit werden sie
ihn konfrontieren und anschließend gibt
der kellner ein überblick darüber welche
meinungen welche artikel schon im faz
einspruch magazin vertreten waren das
ist ja das schriftliche format von
anspruch dass sich insbesondere auch
unseren leserinnen und leser widmet
genau weil sehr viele rufen das ja über
eine app ab und da gibt es ja regelmäßig
exklusiv beiträge wo sich auch eine
ganze palette zum thema impfpflicht
gefunden hat ganz unterschiedliche
beiträge auf die ich nachher eingehen
werde ja und danach herr müller da freue
ich mich schon drauf da werden sie sich
ein bisschen streiten ich werde das
moderieren mit dem stephan rixen dem
jura professor der im deutschen ethikrat
gegen die impfpflicht gestimmt hat sie
haben sich ja in mehreren kommentaren in
der faz für die impfpflicht
ausgesprochen und ich bin sehr gespannt
auf das gespräch und danach wiederum
gibt stephan klenner einen historischen
abriss über das thema impfpflicht nicht
nur weil es gelegentlich auch im
mündlichen prüfungen gefragt wird
sondern weil das durchaus für die
aktuelle debatte auch für die
politischen entscheider bemerkenswert
wichtig sein kann was hat man damals
eigentlich getan wie hat man
argumentiert wie hat man eine
impfpflicht durchgesetzt richtig und
damit nach der ganzen geschichte nicht
zu trocken wird gibt es dann noch ein
gespräch mit unseren karikaturisten aus
der faz greser & lenz von denen kennt
man viele zeichnungen und bilder wir
hören sie dann hier auch mal im ton sie
merken liebe hörer wir haben diesmal
eine sehr sehr volle sendung aber auch
eine sehr spannende sendung mit ganz
unterschiedlichen facetten und jetzt
legen wir auch direkt los
[Musik]
schönen guten tag herr ministerpräsident
bouffier
wir wollen über die impfpflicht treten
wenn sie selbst allein entscheiden
können wann kommt die impfpflicht für
alle wenn ich alleine entscheiden könnte
dann würde es kommt zum ersten märz und
bis dahin haben wir auch ein paar
grundbedingungen geschaffen wie wir
diese impfpflicht auch praktisch
umsetzen können also das wäre meine
vorstellung wie soll sie denn
durchgesetzt werden nach ihrer
auffassung gut gehen wir mal schauen
also sie kennen ja den alt drei oder
vier klang erstmal muss die maßnahmen
geeignet sein sie muss erforderlich
seien
verhältnismäßig also alles das was wir
üblicherweise prüfen in der
grundüberzeugung dass wir mit einer
impfpflicht die zahl derer die geimpft
werden erhöhen und das nun wiederum dazu
führt dass das schutzniveau der
bevölkerung erhöhtes und wir weitere
wellen die ich erwarte entweder durch
veränderungen des virus oder ganzen
abend das gleiche dann besser in den
griff kriegen und insbesondere die
kollateralschäden die mit vielfachen
eingriffen in die grundrechte verbunden
sind viele menschen dann geringer
ausfallen da komme ich gleich noch mal
zu kaufen würde blickwinkel wie ich das
abwägen wie man das machen kann ich
würde
eine entsprechende maske machen wir
haben die meldedaten aller bürger und
würde dann eine entsprechende
aufforderung an alle geben dass sie ihre
krankheit
geimpft sind in diese maske einstellen
das ist eine art grund register und dann
sieht man ja wer sich nicht gemeldet hat
dann würde ich danach die leute
anschreiben ihnen eine frist geben dass
ich bitte melden entweder sich wieder
ein tragen bzw soweit noch nicht
geschehen dann eine impfung vornehmen
und das auch nachweisen
wenn sie das nicht tun würde ich das mit
einem bußgeld versehen und es würde
natürlich die folge sein wer nicht
kämpft dies kann in bestimmten dingen
nicht teilnehmen das ist einfach mal die
grobe linie
und was die grund abwägung angeht bin
ich sehr bei dem das professor wissmann
mal vor einiger zeit formuliert hat es
geht ja im kern um zwei fragen
das ist ein eingriff die impfung ist
unbestritten und
insofern auch ein wenn man so will ein
eingriff in die freiheit der 2
auf der anderen seite führt das
natürlich dazu dass solange wir viele
nicht geimpfter am tag im grünen bereich
viel erwachsene das zum eingriff in die
freiheit viele andere führt kreuz und
quer durch alle grundrechte das
sehen wir im handel das sehen wir bei
den vereinigungen das gegenüber
veranstaltungen das sehen wir in
vielfältigster weise wo wir durch
einschränkungen grundrechte in anderer
weise doch erhebt nicht angeben und wäre
es denkbar dass man vorher noch ein
weiteres mittel das gleich geeignet ist
stichwort erforderlichkeit ansetzt dass
noch nicht alles getan ist um zu
überzeugen vertrauen aufzubauen
wir haben jetzt gerade wieder diskutiert
auch mit der bundesregierung und den
neuen werbekampagne das ist sehr schön
bei allem was wir feststellen erreicht
die in der regel die leute nicht einfach
sagen interessiert mich nicht es gibt
eine diskussion dass man vorher
vielleicht ein verbindliches
beratungsgespräch macht über sowas kann
man reden aber die vorstellung man müsse
jetzt endlich mal auf bestimmte gruppen
ihm zu gehen das machen wir alles längst
wie ein schönes beispiel dass hessen
zeigen wir haben am wochenende so eine
art mischung von event und impfen
gemacht auf dem flughafen kassel calden
ist die bundeswehr mit einer großen
sport maschine gelandet und das angebot
gemacht hier können die maschinen
besichtigen kriegt auch noch irgendeinen
give away und kriegt auch dabei gleich
die impfung das wird der in ähnlicher
weise alles links gemacht wir gehen vor
die moscheen wir sind mit den vereinen
unterwegs ideen mit den mobilen
einrichtungen auf in die berühmten
schwierigen viertel also ehrlich gesagt
ich habe noch von keinem gehört er sagt
wir müssen jetzt noch etwas neues
erfinden was wir eigentlich noch machen
sollten und was ist unsers sage ich dass
es kein wirkliches anderes mittel gibt
um eine merkliche reaktion zu erfahren
ja und das hieße ja aber auch dass es
gibt so einen prozentsatz von durchaus
einigen millionen die sich dem
bisherigen kampagnen und aufforderungen
verlautbarung verweigern die würden
womöglich auch auf das anschreiben dass
sie ansprachen nicht reagieren würden
auch vielleicht ein bußgeld bezahlen
oder nicht bezahlen was passiert wenn
die das bußgeld jetzt nicht bezahlen
beziehungsweise sich auch dann nach
aufforderung der dann eingeführten
pflicht nachzukommen verweigern nun gut
dann wird man abzuwägen haben was ist
noch verhältnismäßig ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass wird eine
zwangsvorführung machen und die leute zu
impfen das würde ich nicht für
verhältnismäßig halten
die frage ob dann aus einem bußgeld dann
ein zwangsgeld wird wenn ihr auch sehr
zurückhaltend das entscheidende match
ein dass diejenigen die nicht geimpft
sind dann an bestimmten dingen nicht
teilnehmen können dauerhaft im übrigen
muss man ja mal die frage stellen und
das ist mein ausgangspunkt wenn ich
freiheit gegen freiheit nehmen die
freiheit einzelner die durchaus
geringere zahl gegenüber der
einschränkung der freiheit zu vieler
dann ist für mich pflicht
der freiheits überschuss wollen aus
dieser freiheits bilanz der ist
ausdrücklich bei der impfpflicht und wir
können doch nicht jedes thema so
diskutieren nach dem motto wenn es einer
aber nicht macht was machst du denn da
dann kommt man ja immer zum ergebnis wir
sind praktisch handlungsunfähig das
halte ich nicht für richtig wir sind
nicht handlungsunfähig und ich möchte
nicht dass wir noch monate unter
umständen jahre vor der alternative
stehen jetzt nämlich gerade mal den über
60 die nicht geimpft sind oder sie sind
aber besonders gefährdet wie die
wissenschaft und besonders immer wieder
nachweis dass wir wegen denen noch jahre
eine ganze reihe von einschränkungen
haben die nicht nur die menschheit
nerven sondern auch nachhaltige
eingriffe in die grundrechte sind
besteht die gefahr dass man dass der ein
oder andere sich dann doch bequem und
dann bleibt eben die frage das ist ja
oben gekämpft der kommt dann halt in
bestimmten bereichen nicht rein ja das
ist ja jetzt schon so das könnte man
natürlich auch noch anziehen dass er in
bestimmte cafés oder kulturelle
veranstaltung nicht herein kommt aber
was wäre wenn er eben auch sich
praktisch als vermögender meinetwegen
freikaufen kann indem er das bußgeld
gezahlt wird es eine neue spaltung
hervorrufen nun gut meine erwartung ist
wenn einer drei mal das bußgeld zeit es
überlegt dass ich gut dann kommt er
lieber impfen
und was die spaltung angeht wir haben
gesellschaftlich unterschiedliche
situation ich mag das wort nicht dass
die gesellschaft gespalten ist das
trifft die angelegenheit nicht richtig
wir haben einen teil
wie hofft ja auch immer sein mag aber
mit sicherheit ein kleinerer teil der
aus einem ja ich würde mal sagen ideen
und gründe mix sich nicht impfen lassen
will das reicht von den
verschwörungstheoretikern bis zu
menschen die wir auch ernsthafte fragen
haben und
deshalb sage ich immer diejenigen die
sich nicht impfen das ist ja nicht
unsere feinde
sie müssen verstehen dass die
impfpflicht hier ein wie ich finde
angemessenes mittel ist im übrigen ist
das alles nicht neu was mich am
allermeisten wundert ist es diese
debatte so schlecht geführt wird bei den
masern haben wir das nicht gehabt früher
bei den pocken auch nicht aber ich will
mal auf einen anderen umstand hinweisen
wir haben gesetzlich jetzt schon die
pflicht in der bereichsspezifischen
pflicht vorzunehmen alle kernfragen die
verfassungsrechtliche stellt sich doch
da auch wieso wird eigentlich die
debatte nur bei der allgemeine
impfpflicht geführt
und deshalb glaube ich in der summe sind
die grundlinien hier die gleichen wie es
mit sind geeignet sich als erforderlich
wollen wir nicht ersichtlich ist welche
möglich erfolgversprechende dinge man
sonst noch tun könnte und im ergebnis
auch für verhältnismäßig wenn es jetzt
so dringlich ist wie sie auch
beschreiben warum hat die cdu dann
eigentlich nicht einen konkreten
vorschlag gemacht als opposition dass
sie die
cdu-bundestagsfraktion fragen ich weiß
dass darüber diskutiert wird sie sind im
moment in der debatte ob sie das machen
da gibt es eine offene debatte darüber
wie man damit umgeht sind zwei
überlegungen zum einen es gibt die
politische grund diskussion die
regierung muss dem so wichtigen frage
mal vorlegen und die regierung ruft dann
zurück das sei ja das sache des
parlaments sind übrigens eine
gewissensfrage was ich auch für unsinn
halten wenn ich das noch sagen wir haben
weder bei den masern nochmal sonstwas
dass wir gewissensfragen erklärt und was
für mich schlagendste argument ist bei
der bereichsspezifischen impfpflicht
bisher auch keiner auf die idee gekommen
dass zur gewissensfrage zu erheben also
dahinter steht die schlechte note dass
sie keine mehrheit irgendwas haben so
und jetzt gibt es irgendwelche
gruppenanträge und die diskussion so
weit ist sie verfolgen können in der
fraktion aber wie gesagt dass nicht nur
zwei der hand sein ist die frage ob man
solchen gruppen anträgen sich öffnet
oder ob man einen eigenen gemeinsamen
antrag macht als ganze fraktion diese
debatte ist soweit ich das sehe noch
nicht entschieden aber es scheint ja
sozusagen als ob das auch innerhalb der
union die sie ja auch ins
gesamtüberblick auch wenn sie jetzt
nicht ganz nahe an der
bundestagsfraktion sind aber doch das
überblicken natürlich bundesweit scheint
ja auch umstritten zu sein sonst hätte
man ja auch sagen können wir setzen dem
zögern der regierung und diesem erklären
zur gewissensfrage eine relativ
einheitliche front end gegen das sehe
ich so natürlich gibt es in der union
auch unterschiedliche positionen aber
soweit ich das wahrnehmen ist eine sehr
breite unterstützung für diese
allgemeine impfpflicht kann ich nicht
jeden abgeordneten in
beschlag nehmen aber wenn sie mal
schauen wir haben ja auch in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz alle die da
sitzen und ist ja auch eine bunte
mischung uns klar für die allgemeine
impfpflicht ausgesprochen das sind die
unionsminister bin aber auch die spd und
nicht zuletzt dann auch noch der haben
wir als linke immer dabei haben wir auch
kollege kretschmann als grüner aber sie
haben wir nach der union gefragt da sehe
ich das so dass es dort eine breite
unterstützung die aber wie man jetzt
konkret den weg wählte ich um nachsicht
die sind mitten in der diskussion und
ich kann den letzten stand ihnen nicht
sagen wie erklären sie sich dass das
schon angesprochen das ist bei manchen
anderen themenbereich spezifische masern
im pflicht aber auch bei anderen themen
oder im zuge des letzten jahres probleme
schon viel erfahrung sammeln konnte und
wo auch die impfung sich jetzt immer
sichere also zwar nicht schützend aber
schützen vor schweren verläufen erwiesen
haben dass gerade jetzt wieder so viele
argumente vorgebracht werden das war
vielleicht vor einem jahr absolut
berechtigt gewesen aber jetzt kommt
alles hoch als ob das sozusagen der
unbekannte neue eingriffs sei der noch
nie da gewesen ist und die man erstmal
jetzt ausführlich beraten und zu
wissensfragen erklären muss wie wie
kommt das das wird sicher mehrere
ursachen zum einen da darf man ja auch
nicht dran vorbei allem die allgemeine
impfpflicht ausgeschlossen lange zeit
bis wir gelernt haben dass die dinge
sich eben nicht mit
tierischen variante aus china und damit
älter erledigen sondern dass es
weitergeht das ist eine veränderung der
sicht der sache und führt auch zu einer
veränderung der konsequenz wir haben
diesen ablehnen eine sehr bunte mischung
von reis bürgern bis zu menschen die den
gesamten staat ablehnen bis zu
verschwörungstheorien bis zu menschen
die auch sorgen haben die ich sehr gut
nachvollziehen kann aber es ist ja nicht
nur bei uns so im deutschen sprachraum
durchaus aber mittlerweile sehen wir es
ja auch in anderen bereichen
es ist für mich glaube ich eine
situation die sich mischt da wird man
noch intensiver später mal sich das
anschauen müssen und vielleicht auf
erklärungsmuster finden einmal ein
aufbegehren im weitesten sinne gegen die
da oben und
gemischt mit ernsthaften bedenken
ich gucke sehe was in spanien was in
frankreich da los ist die ja mit
pflichten schon viel länger unterwegs
sind ich glaube nicht dass ein rein
deutsches phänomen ist und die ursachen
glaube ich sind ein bündel aber ich
würde mir jetzt nicht anmaßen eine
mögliche fundierte analyse vorzulegen
warum das alles so ist die schlichte
frage ist es ist so noch mal vielleicht
zur cdu jetzt auch in ihrer rolle als
mitglied der führungsmannschaft im bund
warum hört man so wenig generell sie
haben gesagt wird es wird jetzt darüber
diskutiert aber muss das nicht mehr
kommen gerade wenn man jetzt so
entschlossen und mit breiter mehrheit
hat so einmütig einen neuen vorsitzenden
gewählt hat sie sagen es
vielleicht sie haben es ja mitgekriegt
in der letzten woche hat es eine klärung
gegeben ich sehr begrüße durch diese
noble entscheidung von kollegen
brinkhaus sich nicht um den
fraktionsvorsitz mehr zu bewerben haben
wir jetzt endlich mal sagen wir mal
unsere hausaufgaben dahingehend gemacht
dass wir handlungsfähig sind und jetzt
haben sie völlig recht ich erwarte auch
dass durch den neuen vorsitzenden und
die neue führung insgesamt auch diese
dinge klarer konturiert werden damit der
bürger auch weiß woran ist und wie lange
wird es brauchen bis die opposition in
den robotern es war glaub ich auch
roland koch aber auch sieben gewisser
weise ihre rolle gefunden und angenommen
hat und daraus auch kraft schöpfen kann
na ja generell glaube ich dass man wenn
man lange in der regierung warnt dann
hinten die opposition geht braucht eine
partei braucht eine organisation
mindestens ein er zwei jahre bis das
vollkommen angekommen ist und dass man
sich neu aufgestellt hat die strukturen
verändert hat und ähnliches mehr
geschwindigkeit besteht einfach darin
dass hier ständig wahlen sind auch in
diesem jahr diese waren ja erfolgreich
bestritten werden sollen so dass auf der
einen seite des tagesgeschäfts auf der
anderen seite die grundsatzfragen und
zum dritten natürlich die tägliche
herausforderung mit der aktuellen
regierung erledigt werden müssen beim
grundsätze sind wir stecken geblieben da
war frau kam kein bauernhof
parteivorsitzender wollten wir unser
grundsatzprogramm auf den weg bringen
unser neues das ist dann grunde umstände
wie sie als es bekannt sie nicht
gelungen da fangen wir jetzt wieder an
das muss sein das braucht auch zeit das
kann man nicht in zwei monaten raum und
auf der anderen seite was die frage der
politischen tageshandel unfähigkeit
angeht glaube ich ist die tatsache dass
wir jetzt noch mal alles geklärt haben
wir die partei führt er die fraktion
führt
und da gehe ich mal davon aus dass das
relativ bald passiert aber wie gesagt es
kommt täglich ein neues thema
und die wahrnehmung einer opposition ist
eh eingeschränkt zunächst guckt also
dass auch die regierung aber ich bin
zuversichtlich dass das sagen wir mal in
den nächsten zwei monaten sich deutlich
ändern ich nochmal abschließend zur
ausnahme situation die sie ja auch so
bezeichnet haben haben sie es auch
erlebt dass in ihrem umfeld parteilich
aber vielleicht auch sonstiges zuge
dieser pandemie plötzlich dinge geäußert
wurden haltung zum vorschein kamen die
sie überrascht haben in dem sinne dass
da sozusagen nicht nur über mögliche
maßnahmen oder ursachen oder
bekämpfungsmittel gegen die pandemie
gestritten wurde sondern sozusagen auch
eine staats caps es eine haltung zu
verschwörungstheorien oder eine
gläubigkeit gegenüber bestimmten dingen
die nicht dem angeblich mainstream
entsprechen die sie überrascht hat und
womöglich auch bei weiteren krisen
negativ sich auswirken könnte
mich hat überrascht dass
in der leeren persönlichen umfeld liegt
es leute gab und gibt die sagen ich
lasse mich nicht impfen das ist alles
käse
das basiert auf chemie und es ist mein
körper genau das falsche und all das
hätte ich im konkreten fall dort nicht
erwartet das hat aber 0 mit
kritik oder so was wiederum zu tun ich
kenne leute die mir aufschreiben und ich
auch bemerkbar machen die eine
grundsätzlich starts kritische haltung
haben
häufig daher kommt nach dem motto die
politik alles versage büchner und ziehen
uns in das licht die gibt's die sind
nicht sehr viel mehr geworden und jetzt
wenn sie fragen ob es denn ich eines
auge geben muss dass da irgendwas
herangewachsen ist dass diesen staat
grundsätzlich in frage gestellt
die sorge habe ich ich kann den umfang
nicht beschreiben
und deshalb sehr viel damit zu tun dass
wir
nicht so recht möglich über
messinstrumente verfügen was sie
komplett geändert hat ist dass die
kommunikation gerade in diesem bereich
in der regel digital läuft
und diese digitalen blasen sind uci
wissen steuerbar werden sich ja auch zum
teil gesteuert und wie viele es wirklich
sind weiß ich nicht wenn sie werden
teilweise auch genutzt von bestimmten
gruppen das ist alles war aber
da spielt die musik in
anführungsstrichen in den klassischen
medien mit in der regel darüber
berichtet und sorgen geäußert aber da
haben sie ja keinen der sich meldet mit
was weiß ich
aufrufen oder sonstwas so dass die
beobachtung nicht ganz einfach ist ich
nehme was das auf was uns gesagt dass
wir dort teile aus dem rechtsextremen
bereich haben wieder unterwegs sind aber
wenn sie jetzt gerade die
ereignisse wochenende in frankfurt sehen
mit den leuten wieder gelaufen in ihr
hatten ja nur alles im angebot von der
friedenstaube
bis hin zum anti terror und alles
mögliche kann sie nicht glaube dass es
noch eine ja
mehrere druck ist die moment mal eint
dass sie gegen die da oben sind und dass
die impfpflicht oder das impfen ein teil
dieser kampagne ist dass man es jetzt
gut brauchen können und dann gibt es
heute auch ein teil sicherlich die
verdienen geht es um die impfpflicht
zugleich gibt es ja auch den vorwurf
trotz dieser vielfalt auch von blasen im
digitalen raum es gebe eine art
gleichschaltung der wird ja sogar in den
medien in manchen medien oder auch in
der wissenschaft erhoben und selbst das
bundesverfassungsgericht können sich dem
nicht verwehren es geben sozusagen eine
exekutive oder vielleicht auch
parlamentarische gleichschaltung ein
mainstream der sozusagen dann auch von
liegen gerichten oder vermissten sich
noch abgesegnet werden diesem vorwurf
gibt es der so war auch nicht ganz neu
war eine ganze zeit lang politisch
unterwegs ist ist die afd
das reicht ja von fake news lügen presse
system
gleichschaltung und so weiter die
stichworte kennen wir ja schon ein
bisschen länger
und das ist teilweise jetzt übernommen
wird das überrascht mich nicht das macht
die sache ja nicht richtiger aber es ist
die grundlage und sie ich erlebe sie
nicht nur bei uns in deutschland für
mich ist der wirklich entscheidende
resonanzboden staaten von amerika
wirklich bestritten dass überhaupt die
pandemie gibt und was wird nun möglich
in eine freund feind
geschichte wahrgenommen die nichts mehr
anerkennt und dann ist eben bis rauf zum
verfassungsgericht alles entweder
bestochen oder gleichgeschaltet in angst
und wenn gar nichts mehr hilft
psychopharmaka
bedingt nicht mehr in der lage zu
entscheiden war diese leute kommen sie
nicht an da muss der recht hat dann
einfach auch zeigen was in unserem land
geht und was nicht geht ich kann es
nicht ändern und es gefällt mir auch
nicht in jemand mich das weiß ich
gekauft hält und dass ich keine ahnung
von nichts haben und so weiter das muss
man bis zum gewissen geradeaus hat was
man nicht aushalten muss sind
körperliche angriffe nötigungen
bedrohungen da müssen wir mit den
mitteln des rechtsstaats gegenhalten
ganz herzlichen dank herr
ministerpräsident für das gespräch und
ich hoffe wir sprechen uns gelingt
wieder ja weil ich wünsche ihnen noch
einen schönen tag
[Musik]
wir kommen nun zu den schon
angekündigten beiträgen aus dem
einspruch magazin zum thema impfpflicht
herr klenner was haben sie uns dazu
mitgebracht ja wie ich eingangs schon
sagte ganz ganz unterschiedliche
standpunkte zu diesem thema also ich
finde wirklich super spannend wie
unterschiedlich dieses thema diskutiert
wird und das hat man eben auch im
einspruch magazin verfolgen können es
ist so dass man das über fasnet
schrägstrich einspruch oder als app
aufrufen kann und dort dann eben jeden
tag alle juristischen artikel der faz
lesen kann und auch regelmäßig exklusiv
beiträge und diese exklusiv beiträge die
haben sich in letzter zeit eben auch
viel mit dem thema impfpflicht
beschäftigt natürlich können und zuhörer
die auch alle in den shows zum podcast
nachlesen wir werden das entsprechend
verlinken wenn man jetzt mal so ein
bisschen zurückblickt hatten wir zum
beispiel einen beitrag von till steffen
ehemaliger justizsenator der grünen in
hamburg jetzt im bundestag und der ist
einer der befürworter für die
impfpflicht ab 18 und ich fand das ganz
spannend das ist am selben tag
erschienen die wir im blatt auch ein
beitrag hatten im interview mit dem
fdp-abgeordneten ullmann der ja für eine
impfpflicht ab 50 ist und so konnten
dann die leser die argumente direkt so
ein bisschen vergleichen und kurz zuvor
gab es dann noch einen deutlich
kritischeren beitrag zum thema
impfpflicht von ulrich silberbach das
ist ja der bundesvorsitzende vom
deutschen beamtenbund und der macht sich
so ein bisschen sorgen wie könnte so
eine impfpflicht überhaupt umgesetzt
werden ja haben wir da genug personal
und er weist eben da auch auf mögliche
probleme hin und dazu in kontrast stand
dann ein beitrag von christiane richter
der ist dozent an der führungsakademie
der bundeswehr und der sarg tatsächlich
es gibt sogar eine verfassungsrechtliche
pflicht eine impfpflicht einzuführen
also das grundgesetz gebietet dass er
begründet das unter anderem mit der
ersten abtreibungs entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts da wurde ja
eine schutzpflicht des staates für das
menschliche leben abgeleitet und in der
entscheidung zur schleyer entführung hat
dann das bundesverfassungsgericht
festgestellt dass sich diese
schutzpflicht durchaus auch auf ein
bestimmtes mittel verdichten kann
christian richter meint eben jetzt in
pandemie zeiten wäre das der fall und
dieses einzige mittel wäre eine
impfpflicht ja das sei so als als
kleiner überblick aber herr müller sie
hatten dann auch noch ein interessantes
gespräch mit udo di fabio früheren
bundesverfassungsrichter was hatte er
ihn so erzählt genau
bundesverfassungsrichter und tanz dampf
in allen verfassungsrechtlichen gassen
der hat mir auf staat und recht in
interviewform erzählt dass er durchaus
einer impfpflicht für möglich und
vertretbar hält sich aber auch nicht
obwohl er gar nicht mehr im amt ist als
richter festlegen wollte aber ganz
interessant ausgeführt hat doch mal die
probleme die sich beim vollzug auftun
könnten was macht man wenn jemand sich
hartnäckig weigert was tut man wenn
jemand bußgelder bezahlt dass ich
vielleicht frei kaufen will wie setzt
man auf verhältnismäßige weise eine
impfpflicht um und er hat noch ein
bisschen philosophiert wie das auch sein
markenzeichen ist zum thema freiheit und
einen freiheitsbegriff der sich von
sämtlichen bindungen löst als schwierig
erachtet das war also ganz spannend aber
auch mit blick auf die frage dass
vielleicht auch impfgegner oder
impfpflicht gegner nicht stigmatisiert
werden dürfen also wie wir miteinander
umgehen wir auch thema aber wohlgemerkt
erhält eine impfpflicht durchaus auch
für möglich und vertretbar stellt sich
eher die frage des vollzugs bei ihm ja
ich fand noch spannend so ein bisschen
dieses ganze thema datenschutz da wird
ja im zusammenhang mit der impfpflicht
auch immer stark darüber diskutiert weil
viele das ja verknüpfen brauchen wir ein
impf register wenn wir eine impfpflicht
einführen da haben wir mit rolf
schwartmann einen beitrag gemacht der
schreibt das ganze ist
datenschutzrechtlich möglich mit so
einem register wenn der zweck des
registers klar und grenzt ist und ja
dann gab es noch einen beitrag von peter
biesenbach das ist der justizminister
von nordrhein-westfalen und er hat sich
so ein bisschen mit der frage
auseinandergesetzt ist das ganze
eigentlich eine gewissensfrage er sagt
nein das ist eigentlich keine
gewissensfrage das hätte im parlament so
ganz klassisch entschieden wird werden
können in den fraktionen und natürlich
ist auch so ein bisschen die frage ist
es vielleicht auch eine ablenkung von
ihm weil er erzielt als er auf die ampel
man muss aber sagen das ist ja in der
union das wurde ja vorhin in ihrem
gespräch mit volker bouffier deutlich
auch ganz unterschiedliche positionen zu
dem thema gibt ja und dann haben wir
noch einen beitrag von rainer schmidt
früherer staatsrechtler an der uni
augsburg und der geht so ein bisschen
diesem thema spaltung der gesellschaft
nach weil das ja auch immer wieder
sowohl von befürwortern als auch von
gegnern einer impfpflicht als argument
angeführt wird und er sagt naja das mit
der spaltung das ist eigentlich gar
nicht so schlimm weil unsere demokratie
lebt auch ein stück weit von spaltung
und von streit sonst funktioniert
ziemlich das fand ich auch noch einen
sehr spannenden gedanken
hier haben wir jetzt zum streitgespräch
einmal stephan rixen er ist professor
für öffentliches recht sozial
wirtschafts und gesundheitsrecht an der
universität bayreuth er ist mitglied des
deutschen ethikrates und hat mit drei
weiteren mitgliedern des ethikrates auf
fasnet dargelegt warum er einer
ausgeweiteten impfpflicht nicht folgen
kann und er diskutiert jetzt mit
reinhard müller verantwortlicher
redakteur für faz einspruch und für das
zeitgeschehen bei der faz reinhard
müller war ja vorhin schon in der
sendung und hat sich in mehreren
kommentaren dezidiert für eine
impfpflicht
ausgesprochen und die beiden wollen
jetzt miteinander diskutieren herzlich
willkommen
guten tag guten tag ericsson ja herr
professor rixen viele menschen hoffen
darauf durch die impfpflicht aus dieser
dauerschleife von corona maßnahme zu
kommen sie haben geschrieben dass sie
diese hoffnung nicht teilen warum nicht
also ich da alle die hoffnung nicht dass
die impfpflicht wenn sie völlig unklar
innerlich bleibt wirklich erlösung ist
wir reden häufig nicht im detail darüber
was mit dem pflicht gemeint ist und das
war eigentlich etwas was für uns bei der
intervention in fahrt das wichtigste war
darauf hinzuweisen dass wir nicht sang
ein abstraktes symbol für die
aufführungen darauf dass alles besser
wird diskutieren sondern dass wir im
detail fragen was ist das ziel der
impfpflicht haben wir die mittel auch
damit nicht funktioniert das gilt für
die impfstoffe etwa mit blick auf neue
virusvarianten das gilt aber auch für
die infrastruktur
und wir müssen uns auch die frage
stellen ist das durchsetzbar und welche
mittel wollen wir auf wänden etwa was
die fragen angeht anwendung von zwang
und sanktionen sondern pflicht dann auch
umzusetzen all das schien uns nicht
hinreichend klar ich glaube wenn wir
klarheit darüber haben können wir auch
viel besser einschätzen ist eine
impfpflicht wirklich eine hilfe ist es
nicht ist es für sie hinreichend klar
herr müller sie haben geschrieben in der
faz die impfpflicht sei ein klacks ja
allerdings ist das das ergebnis eines
längeren prozesses vor einem jahr noch
hätte ich das habe ich das auch anders
gesehen habe es auch so geschrieben
damals war ja erstens noch unklar
zunächst ob es überhaupt impfstoffe
geben wird dann war die unsicherheit mit
den nebenfolge es gab ja immerhin bei
einigen impfstoffen auch todesfälle bei
jungen frauen bei jungen menschen einige
empfehlungen geben auch dahin über
30-jährigen zu impfen die lage völlig
anders und natürlich habe ich es auch so
gesehen als freiheitsliebender mensch
und auch aus verfassungsgründen
letztes mittel beziehungsweise erst mal
überzeugen und es war noch gar kein
mittel zunächst meine meinung hat sich
insofern geändert als sich natürlich
auch die
lager zum einen auf der impfstoff front
geändert hat zwar hat sich auch nicht
absolut sich alles bewahrheitet was mit
dem stoff erhofft wurde aber man sieht
eben doch dass die fachleute sagen wir
müssen die impf lücke schließen wir
müssen das gesundheitssystem schützen
und das sozusagen eine möglichst breite
impfung das beste mittel sei
und in der tat ich würde auch sagen es
kommt auf die ausgestaltung an aber es
ist eben immer noch so dass bis vor
kurzem jedenfalls das gesundheitssystem
an der grenze war das kann auch schnell
wieder passieren werden die zahlen in
absoluter form auch bei der relativ
milden variante um ii konnten wieder
hochgehen und insofern glaube ich dass
die impfpflicht sondern sie auch mit
anderen pflichten vergleicht und wenn
man auch die bisherige rechtsprechung
dazu betracht zieht in der tat absolut
vertretbar ist ein legitimen zweck
verfolgt noch angemessen durchgesetzt
werden kann sind das für sie auch
abwägungs parameter die da noch alle
spielen ericsson also und ist es ihnen
vor allem genug klarheit und so eine
impfpflicht für realistisch zu halten
also da dann fehlt mir tatsächlich schon
etwas also die frage ist ja man sieht
das ja manchmal österreich richtet die
kleinen teil liegt man die dinge regeln
muss und wie man sich allerdings auch
kleinteilig regeln kann und ich glaube
auch solch einem konkretisierung niveau
sind wir in deutschland immer noch nicht
angekommen also die erste frage ist er
tatsächlich was ist denn das ziel der
impfpflicht also geht es um den schutz
von personen so ist das ja das eine ziel
gewesen dass etwa bei der einrichtung
bezogenen impfpflicht genannt wurde also
wurde dort auch in der begründung
genannt das ziel überhaupt die impfquote
zu erhöhen was natürlich zusammenhängt
das setzt aber voraus dass wir
tatsächlich auch in der situation
gekommen wo diese gefährdung der
funktionsfähigkeit des gesundheitswesens
auch absehbar ist oder wahrscheinlich
ist dass jetzt umgekehrt wiederum frau
zuerst wissen wie sich die dinge
weiterentwickeln
also was mir ein leuchten würde wäre
dass wir vielleicht wenn das irgendwie
vernünftig gestaltbar wäre so eine art
impfpflicht oft vorrat verabschieden die
dann vielleicht im herbst dann aktiviert
werden kann aber auch da muss doch klar
sein eine impfpflicht ist doch nur
sinnvoll wenn ich im stoffe habe die
dann auch wirken also wir müssen noch
mit einigen unsicherheiten doch erst
einmal klarkommen und darum meine ich
allein jetzt zu behaupten dass die
impfpflicht wenn die umweg backen und
sich hätten so groß sind wird ist doch
mehr hoffnung als irgendwie
gestützt eine prognose gestützt auf
wirkliche tatsachen also ich glaube wir
müssen dann sagen ab wann soll sie
gelten wie gehen wir mit der
unsicherheit um das vielleicht impfstoff
erst mal weiter entwickelt werden müssen
all das muss man zumindest mal fragen
wenn man darauf vernünftige antworten
hat dann finde ich auch ist es
vertretbar eine solche pflicht
vielleicht auf vorrat zu verabschieden
aber sie tat es darf nicht nur ein
symbol bleiben ohne all diese ganz
praktischen fragen auch ganz konkret zu
behandelt wurden und das würde ich auch
so sehen man muss es jedenfalls sich
darum kümmern muss es vorher schon und
zwar jetzt
überlegen und sich überlegen wann kann
man unter umständen mit diesem mittel
kommen es kann ja sein dass wir uns dann
im herbst sagen wenn man es nicht tut
haben wir jetzt nicht wieder ein halbes
jahr verschenkt und das war ja auch was
die schutzpflicht des staates angeht
fatal also wie ging es nur darum dass
das mittel als solches wenn man es denn
richtig ausgestaltet und zur anwendung
bringt kann es wegs völlig fremd oder
verfassungswidrig ist und das wurde ja
gelegentlich behauptet als ob sozusagen
der schutz der körperlichen
unversehrtheit um die es hier geht
ein mega grundrecht wäre wir kennen ja
auch andere eingriffe und es fehlt mir
so ein bisschen die abwägung zu den
angriffen die wir sonst so erdulden
müssten die wir vielleicht auch er töten
müssen wenn wir uns jetzt nicht um eine
impfpflicht kümmern wir haben ja auch
die einrichtungs bezogenen lange
verzögert ja ich gebe ihnen recht dass
wir uns einmal genau die frage stellen
müssen was löst eigentlich das unbehagen
bei vielen menschen aus und dass die
frage natürlich berechtigt ist findet
hier auf den ersten blick zumindest
nicht eine merkwürdige überhöhung des
schutzes der körperlichen integrität
statt andererseits muss man schon auch
sagen dass das bundesverfassungsgericht
gerade in seiner jüngeren rechtsprechung
bei der frage von eingriffen in die
körperliche unversehrtheit ja nicht nur
artikel 2 absatz 2 satz 1 wo die
körperliche unversehrtheit erwähnt wird
nennt sondern gleichzeitig auch sagt es
geht um das allgemeine
persönlichkeitsrecht das heißt da haben
wir dann auch noch immer diesen
menschenwürde in tag und ich will damit
nicht sagen dass jeder eingriff percy
und zulässig wäre weil es da irgendwie
menschenwürde hintergrund auch hier zur
geltung käme ich will nur deutlich
machen dass ich diese rechtsprechung für
sehr vernünftig halte die anforderungen
an eingriffe in die körperliche
unversehrtheit auch sehr sehr stark zu
machen von strengen hürden sozusagen
ausdrücken die gesetzgeber überspringen
muss denn es ist doch manchmal schon
erstaunlich auch in der jetzigen
diskussion wie freihändig wir über
sozusagen ja quasi zwangs angriffe ich
das wort zwar muss man ja vorsichtig
verwenden aber sagen wir mal davon
ausgehen dass eingriffe der sache nach
mit jedenfalls mit einem gewissen druck
und gesundheit erfolgen dürfen wo wir
sonst im gesundheitsrecht doch immer
wahnsinnig darauf achten dass die
einbeziehung ernst genommen wird also es
hat schon auch damit zu tun darum würde
ich sagen auf den ersten blick ist das
vielleicht verwunderlich dass die
körperliche unversehrtheit zu stärken
oder es wird hat damit zu tun dass die
menschen offenbar eben ihren körper wenn
man das so ein bisschen traditionell
ausdrücken darf es als ausdrucks feld
ihrer individualität begreifen dass es
eben nicht um eine irgendwie moneymoney
kolibris extender geht sondern um sie
selbst nehmen und ich glaube diese
dimension die muss man vielleicht nicht
teilen aber ich glaube das erklärt ein
wenig warum ist auch unbehagen es gibt
natürlich leute die völlig jenseits von
gut und böse ansichten vertreten im
bereich das ist mir schon bewusst und
wir sollten da nicht alle in diese ecke
tun aber wir sollten uns fragen wo
dieses unbehagen herkommen und ich meine
diese bedeutung des körpers für die
eigene individualität die muss zumindest
irgendwie vorkommen und dann gebe ich
ihm recht herr müller müssen wir uns
generell die frage stellen wie werden
auch plötzlich körperliche integrität
und auch gemeinwohlinteressen zueinander
verhalten ist eine diskussion die jetzt
in der panini eigentlich erst so richtig
mal dass bei diesen gesundheitsfragen
deutlich wird und die darf nicht zu kurz
kommen sie haben jetzt zwei grundrechte
genannt ericsson körperliche
unversehrtheit und allgemeines
persönlichkeitsrecht
aber muss man nicht eben auch auf die
waagschale die ganzen anderen
grundrechte werfen die zurzeit hier
eingeschränkt werden also das
versammlungsrecht wird massiv
eingeschränkt auch allgemeine
handlungsfreiheit in ganz vielen
unterschiedlichen facetten
berufsfreiheit viele gruppen wird wird
eingeschränkt gehört das nicht auch zu
so einer abwägung dazu und ist dann
wirklich eine impfpflicht noch so ein
gravierender eingriff
ich glaube schon dass das in eine
gesamtabwägung darauf einzustellen ist
ich würde noch ergänzen also die ganzen
dramen das kann man nicht anders sagen
die sich abspielen bei kinder und
jugendlichen also wenn man mit menschen
spricht die kinderpsychiatrie zu tun
haben die die sagen gekommen bekommen
gar nicht mehr nach was die arbeit da
ist also es ist wirklich dramatische
entwicklungen das gilt natürlich auch
für das bildungswesen für den
kita-bereich die schulen das ist alles
richtig insofern bin ich der meinung
dass das selbstverständlich eingestellt
werden muss dann bleibt aber trotzdem
noch die frage sind wir uns denn so
sicher und das ist doch eine
interessante frage dass eine impfpflicht
und ging man muss mal sagen was heißt
das denn eigentlich genau dass er nicht
mehr pflicht den unterschied macht zu
dem was wir jetzt ja da war ich kurz
einhalten wollen in der tat das ist der
punkt den ich auch vor einem jahr noch
anders gesehen hätte und
argumentiert haben muss überzeugen
überzeugen die durch wellige angebote
machen vertrauen aufbauen und so weiter
man sieht natürlich nur trotz der
faszinierenden zahl finde ich weiterhin
beim 80 millionen volk eine
75-prozentige voll impfung jedenfalls
zweifach-impfung durchsetzt haben jetzt
kommt man an eine grenze ist ja ganz
offensichtlich es geht nur sehr sehr
langsam voran wohl die booster impfung
bei denen die eben überzeugt sind und
vertrauen haben auch ganz gut laufen und
klar sowohl am anfang gesagt ausreichend
vielleicht 70 75 prozent aus jetzt
anscheinend nicht und genau dann ist
eben die frage wie kommt man über diese
hürde und so ein bisschen finde ich
jetzt nach monat nach vielen monaten
auch der maßnahmen jetzt auch eine
bundeswehr general an der spitze und
sicherlich auch noch mit defiziten im
digitalen bereich vielleicht auch
marketingmäßig aber man kommt
anscheinend an eine wand und es gibt ja
auch das argument auch das ethische
argumente wenn man so will auch das
argument des allgemeinen gesetzes das
eine allgemeine impfpflicht auch
entlastend wirkt weil sie eben
denjenigen die sonst vielleicht oder
irgend welchen zwängen oder aus faulheit
aber auch vielleicht weil sich wissen
kreisen bewegen
dann sagen kann gut jetzt ist das gesetz
und ich bin eben kein
ablehner kein querdenker im schlimmen
sinne sondern ich folge jetzt der
gesetzlichen pflicht
und macht das jetzt also zeigen die
entlastende wirkung des allgemeinen
gesetzes aber herr müller die querdenker
gibt es ja schon auch also absolut ist
denn bei denen durch sandie clair genau
und die sind glaube ich auch nicht
erreichbar also es gibt einen festen
kern den ich jetzt nicht so einschätzen
kann von nicht unbedingt jetzt
verfassungsfeinden aber sozusagen von
leuten die das partout ablehnen und
vielleicht dann auch paar
verschwörungstheorien dazu stricken und
die durchsetzung würde ich auch sagen
ist eine frage aber man darf auch die
jetzt nicht so überhören dass man sagt
eine pflicht können wir nicht
durchsetzen und deswegen können sie
nicht einführen es ist ja auch sonst so
dass man das hinnimmt dass es einen
gewissen anteil gibt von leuten die sich
nicht an gesetze halten an regeln klar
hier stellen sich verschiedene fragen
also kann man sich frei kaufen wenn man
das bußgeld eben zahlt mehrfach zeit wie
wird das letztlich durchgesetzt aber ich
finde auch der aspekt dass wir in weiten
teilen des gesellschaftlichen lebens
jetzt schon und das wäre vielleicht noch
ausbaufähig ja eine faktische
impfpflicht haben für alle die in cafés
gehen wollen vielleicht aber die auf
reisen gehen wollen ich finde es
interessant dass abgesehen jetzt von
niedersachsen und auch bayern aber das
waren ja auch gründe die man beheben
konnte weil das natürlich stimmig sein
muss dass da keiner sagt das wäre ja
auch ein argument nein das ist absolut
verfassungswidrig dass sich leute so
weit aus dem gesellschaftlichen
kulinarischen
reise leben ausschließe scheint ja
irgendwie auf konsens zu treffen
jedenfalls im sozial nicht unbedingt auf
konsens also der gang ja schon auch sehr
viel kritik an diesem grau aber die
scheint da das wird sozusagen
gewisser weise noch hingenommen und es
ist ja schon auch eine faktische
impfpflicht im wasenwald wenn man wenn
man denn sie nicht als eremit bewegt und
sich das essen liefern ist ja ja aber da
würde mich schon interessieren herr
müller wie weit würden sie denn gehen
also sie haben jetzt gesagt bußgeld
zahlungen würden sie machen für die
impfpflicht würden sie denn dann
irgendwann auch eine erzwingungshaft
machen oder geht ihnen das zu weit man
könnte ja grenze also ich finde es gibt
ja rechts historisch auch das hat dabei
sind die vermögensabgabe wo man
wenigstens verhindern würde dass man das
jetzt aber nur ehrenpaaren these dass
wirklich der eine sich freikaufen können
der andere nicht aber wir kennen ja auch
aus dem straßenverkehr auch viele
verstöße oder nachhaltige verstöße
können auch nicht durch zahlung
beglichen werden soll müssen dann
trotzdem mögen wie geahndet wenn man
kann seinen führerschein verlieren dann
sehr sehr oft falsch parkt aber ich
finde man könnte ja auch anders ansetzen
und noch mal fragen ist alles
ausgeschöpft vor diesen überlegungen
stichwort der arbeitnehmer vielleicht
nicht nur einrichtungs bezogen bekommt
nur dann geld wenn er auf leute trifft
wenn jemand auf leute trifft sei es am
arbeitsplatz sei es woanders muss er den
flach weiß haben sonst kriegt ja kein
geld das ist natürlich sehr hart und das
ist ja natürlich auch
verfassungsrechtlich problematisch und
diskussionswürdig aber er muss ich dann
eben entscheiden und es wie bei den
pflegekräften hat unter umständen auch
droht der jobverlust wenn man dem nicht
nachkommt ericsson würde sie das
überzeugen also quasi durchsetzung der
impfpflicht mit gegebenenfalls lohn
entzug also es sind vielleicht zwei
aspekte das eine ist ja was verstehen
wir letztlich eine frage der
erforderlichkeit also man kann in der
tat ja sagen das ist eine skala man kann
ja den impf druck nach und nach erhöhen
oder ist ja letztlich geschehen was man
so landläufig indirekte impfpflicht
nennt diese zweijährige sind ja nichts
anderes dass ich letztlich versuche
menschen
über den ausschluss aus bestimmten
bereichen des gesellschaftlichen lebens
dazu zu bringen sich impfen zu lassen
die frage ist natürlich hat man erst mal
noch etwas abwarten können wie
erfolgreich das ist dann kann man das
sieht noch ausbauen dieses dieses
instrument das eine frage der
erforderlichkeit muss natürlich ein
einschätzungsspielraum gibt das ist mir
schon auch klar wenn wir jetzt uns die
frage stellen wie könnte man mit anderen
anderer weise noch nachteile sozusagen
in anschlag bringen
können wir wahrscheinlich bald erleben
wie die einrichtungs bezogene ihm fliegt
funktioniert oder nicht funktioniert
leider hat der gesetzgeber nicht den mut
gehabt klare arbeitsrechtliche regeln zu
schaffen hat das in der
gesetzesbegründung versteckt und da bin
ich relativ sicher dass es da noch viele
probleme gegeben wird wenn man mit den
wohlfahrtsverbänden spricht da deuten
viele auch den personalbereich
verantwortung haben schon an das ist da
auch wo absehbar arbeits regel konflikte
geben wird wenn man auf solche
instrumente setzt wie sie herr müller
andeutet dann muss man sie auch klar
regeln man kann sie nicht der praxis
überlassen und dann auch den
arbeitsgerichten wobei man ja bedenken
muss er bei der einrichtung des
bezogenen impfpflicht dass die ja
ohnehin noch bis ende des jahres dauert
also da werden auch für
arbeitsrechtliche konsequenzen schon gar
nicht vor den gerichten ausgetragen sein
und letztlich leer laufen und das würde
wenn man das nicht klar regelt letztlich
auch für eine allgemeine helmpflicht
gelten also das meine ich mit meinem
punkt was meint allgemeine impfpflicht
man kann über viele sanktionen
nachdenken das müssen jetzt nicht
bußgelder seien das können auch andere
sanktionen seien man muss hier aber
klare regeln damit alle beteiligten
wissen was auf sie zukommt einerseits
und andererseits auch dass die
verantwortlichen etwa arbeitgeber- und
andere genau wissen was ja das würde ich
auch so sehen andererseits ist es
natürlich auch so man kann auch dinge
klar ausschließen das sehen wir auch in
österreich das österreichische gesetz
fängt gleich damit an gleich am anfang
seien dinge die im krieg kann nicht mit
unmittelbaren zwang durchgesetzt werden
und am ende heißt es dann auch dass etwa
auch wenn jemand dann entsprechende
sanktionen nicht bezahlt dass das dann
nicht umgewandelt werden kann in
freiheitsentziehung also man kann sich
auch durchaus als start bestimmter auf
den ersten blick durchaus harte
sanktionen bedient aber doch auch
grenzen einziehen und sagen das kommt
für uns nicht in frage weil vielleicht
auch wenn man da zu hart durchgreifen
würden wenn das überhaupt praktisch geht
auf das täte da wäre das vielleicht auch
ein zu hoher einbuße an legitimation
insgesamt wenn der staat jetzt hier auch
zu hart auftritt also man kann in der
tat viele instrumente erwägen kann die
auch regel man muss es dann auch tun und
das vermisse ich bei der ganzen debatte
zum bei der einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht mit der unklarheit über die
arbeits und sozialrechtlichen folgen wie
ist das etwa mit sperrzeiten wie ist das
mit unzumutbarkeit hartz4 und ähnlichem
wenn dann jemand eine arbeit aufgibt
oder auch verliert die dinge sind alle
nicht gelingt und dass eine impfpflicht
ist nur so viel wert wie sie auch von
der rechtsform her klar geregelt ist und
das ist etwas was glaube ich auch bei
der anstehenden diskussion bedacht
werden also ich erlebt sie jetzt hier in
dem gespräch gar nicht als so krassen
impfpflicht gegner wie ich das
ehrlicherweise im vorfeld vermutet hatte
sondern ich habe eher den eindruck sie
sagen man muss es eben ganz genau regeln
damit es funktioniert warum haben sie
dann im ethik rat dagegen gestimmt und
nicht zum beispiel vorschläge gemacht
wie man es regeln könnte wir haben und
dabei bleibe ich auch gesagt da steht ja
auch in dem fasnet beitrag dass wir
nicht generell gegen eine allgemeine
impfpflicht sind wir glauben nicht dass
gegenwärtig die voraussetzungen und das
war unser punkt den wir ein problem
hatten voraussetzungen dafür bestehen
dass man eine die einführung einer
allgemeinen pflicht empfiehlt wobei dann
immer noch die frage ist wie allgemein
ist allgemein da gab es ja damals
ethikrat bei dem mehrheitsvotum zwei
unterschiedliche ansichten ab 18 jahre
oder dann ja mit einem höheren alter und
wir haben gesagt es gibt zu viele
unklarheiten und das gilt auch das muss
ich noch mal betonen für die frage was
ist das ziel der impfpflicht also was
soll eigentlich damit bezweckt werden
und haben wir die mittel dafür also wir
können doch nicht einfach ins blaue
hinein eine impfpflicht verabschieden
ohne zu wissen welche impfstoffe glaubt
zur verfügung stellung gegen welche
virusvarianten sie sich richten das muss
doch zumindest mal klar genannt werden
und wenn wir uns auch wiederum das
österreichische gesetz ansehen dass es
da wirklich sehr minutiös geregelt sehr
kleinteilig oder so muss das gemacht
werden also wir können auch nicht in
deutschland zu tun als ließe sich das
alles so wahnsinnig kompliziert regeln
österreich zeigt dass wenn man es will
sehr kleinteilig und genau geregelt
werden können und dann kann man sich
nicht hat auch mit blick auf österreich
die frage stellen was ist denn wenn sich
etwa die impfstoffe weiterentwickeln
müssen was ist wenn neue virusvarianten
gekommen da haben die österreicher eine
lösung gefunden von der ich nicht sicher
bin ob sie in deutschland
verfassungsgemäß wäre weil sie dem
zuständigen schatzministerium der
relativ weitreichende kompetenz
einräumen um anpassungen des gesetzes
vorzunehmen ich glaube dass das in
deutschland nicht so möglich wäre aber
das wäre auch nicht wirklich ein problem
denn wir haben in der pandemie gesehen
dass in wenigen tagen grundlegend der
gesetzesänderung vorgenommen werden
können also das lässt sich alles regeln
ich glaube die kernfrage ist nicht die
ob man überhaupt irgendwie eine
impfpflicht regeln kann wenn dann muss
sie präzise geregelt sei müssten die
rechtsfolgen klar sein das scheint mir
wirklich das einmaleins zu sein die
kernfrage ist haben wir eine klarheit
über das tier wissen ja wie lange die
impfpflicht dauern soll wird sie
jahrelang jetzt angeordnet oder
vielleicht nur ein jahr wie sind dass
die mehrfach im 5 4 in führung sind es
mehr irgendwelche impfstoffe sind denn
eigentlich wer entscheidet darüber ob
wirksamen stoffe vorliegen bezogen auf
welche virusvarianten das sind doch die
fragen geklärt sein müssen sonst kann
ich ja letztlich gar nicht auch
entscheiden bei einer
verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung habe ich ein
geeignetes mittel denn das ist ja wenn
ich ein impfstoff habe der überhaupt
nicht wirklich noch geeignet ist
hinreichend geeignet ist das nicht auch
gerade nach wie wir erleben auch bei
omikron dass da viel ist jetzt im wandel
ist ich glaube die wir werden erleben
dass die impfstoffe schnell angepasst
werden aber ein bisschen zeit braucht es
dafür auch und insofern sollten diese
fragen diskutiert werden also nicht eine
abstrakte bejahung der impfpflicht und
sagen ja wir brauchen die impfpflicht
sondern wir müssen auch glaube ich den
politischen betrieb dazu drängen zu
sagen sagt uns genau wie ihr diese
kleinteiligen probleme löst und dann
geht es mir aber auch den anderen die
sich seinerzeit kritisch geäußert haben
falls nicht dann so dass wir sagen wenn
das geklärt ist dann ist auch eine
empfehlung eine allgemeine impfpflicht
einzuführen vertretbar aber wenn das
nicht gibt es da ja ich meine mit mit
diesen unklarheiten da haben sie ja auf
jeden fall einen ganz gewichtigen punkt
es ist ja beachtlich was nach zwei
jahren pandemie alles noch unklar ist
man weiß sehr wenigen zum beispiel
darüber wo sich eigentlich leute
anstecken herr müller befürchten sie
nicht auch dass es sein könnte selbst
wenn jetzt ihre forderungen nach einer
schnellen einführung der impfpflicht
verwirklicht werden würde das dann
karlsruhe im rahmen von so einer
verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung sagt solange
das nicht geklärt ist wo eigentlich die
ansteckungswege sind so lang wurden eben
nicht mildere mittel ausgeschöpft das
fürchte ich weniger weil ja die bundes
notbremsen entscheidung deutlich gemacht
hat dass karlsruhe dem gesetzgeber in
diesem fall anscheinend einen besonders
weiten spielraum zubilligt und wenn er
ein einigermaßen stimmiges gesamtgefüge
präsentiert dann wird das durchgehend
wobei natürlich klar ist also wenn es
offensichtlich evident nicht geeignet
ist den verein stoff zusätzliche zu
gesetzgeber auch nicht ein aber ich
glaube der grund wieder der deutschen
politik war das eben die impfung als
solche die impfpflicht als solche schon
frühzeitig ausgeschlossen worden war
zuerst und es wurde sozusagen der wege
schaffen was noch jedenfalls so obwohl
man auch hätte sagen können auf die
entsprechende frage die natürlich damals
schon kam das ist eine unklare
gefahrenlage die gefahr kann sich so
entwickeln und die können impfstoffe
haben dass wir zu einer impfpflicht
kommen müssen wir tun alles dafür dass
es nicht so ist weil das letzte mittel
sein muss stattdessen an sie kategorisch
zuerst ausgeschlossen musste das dann
wieder quasi auf essen hat dadurch schon
die verunsicherung geschaffen hat
dadurch schon den eindruck erweckt die
impfpflicht ist sozusagen für einen
verfassungsstaat gar kein taugliches
mittel das hat sich in den köpfen
festgesetzt und jetzt steht man eben vor
der frage dass plötzlich wiederum
verkehrte welt ganz viele sagen ja ich
bin persönlich bis hin zum kanzler für
eine impfpflicht halte das auch für
sinnvoll aber ich will kein antrag
vorlegen es ist eine gewissensfrage
und da frage ich mich schon wenn man
selbst sagt ich halte das nicht nur für
mich dass er keine mode frage für
richtig sondern ich halte es auch
allgemein für sinnvoll warum man dann
nicht auch einen übergreifenden antrag
war ein regierungsantrag vorlegt
um eben klar zu machen die gehen hier
voran und dann müssen wir natürlich in
die fragen die wir angesprochen hatten
auch klären durchsetzung bestimmt hat
usw aber das ist jetzt wieder das
gegenteil von ausschluss jetzt ist man
irgendwie dafür aber schaffte es nicht
das zu regeln man kann es ja in der tat
auf vorrat regeln oder jedenfalls als
instrument bereithalten moment sieht die
anlage ja an den kliniken zumindest was
den krankheits grad hospitalisierung
skala ganz gut aus trotz der steigenden
instanzen aber trotzdem kann sich das ja
auch schnell ändern und das ist ein
gewisses missverhältnis an dem
gearbeitet werden muss wobei da würde
ich gerne zwischenrufen was die bundes
notbremse entscheidung angeht also ich
glaube klar dass waren bezogen auf die
bundes notbremse ein vergleichsweise
dass da wohl glaube ich sagen
weitreichende einschätzungs und
gestaltungsspielraum
muss allerdings auch schon sehen dass
das gericht mit blick auf
wissensdefizite zum beispiel vor schluss
defizite auch angemahnt hat das dass da
auch den gesetzgeber eine pflicht trifft
also insofern glaube ich kann es sich
der gesetzgeber nicht ganz so einfach
machen und zu sagen ich lass mal offen
wo denn jetzt überhaupt menschen sich
anstecken oder ob sich bestimmte auch
bereiche gibt in denen tatsächlich auch
eben bereich spezifische agiert werden
ist also insofern finde ich den hinweis
schon auch wichtig ob das am ende da
erreicht in karlsruhe da kann man
natürlich muss man immer vorsichtig sein
solche prognosen abzugeben aber ich
glaube das brauche ich jetzt auch falsch
wäre zu sagen dass es mir in ihren
freifahrtschein für den gesetzgeber
jetzt alles und jedes durchzuwinken wenn
dann gesagt wir brauchen das in der
pandemie also ich würde eher sagen das
war eine entscheidung ganz klar mit
blick auf die bundes naturschutz
gaben zur verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung
aber eben auch solchen die klar machen
die verhältnismäßigkeit prüfung muss
schon auch mit guten gründen erfolgen
auch im chemischen gründen und da glaube
ich hab's wirklich und das ist
eigentlich was mich auch tatsächlich
enttäuscht muss ich sagen so dass wir
den ersten monaten meine treiben in den
ersten acht neun monaten markiert noch
nicht viel wussten aber spätestens nach
einem jahr und dann jetzt nach zwei
jahren das ist eigentlich kaum zu fassen
wie viel nicht wissen es gibt und ich
finde dass das muss schon auch eine
rolle spielen jetzt bei den
anforderungen die eine impfpflicht zu
stellen es geht ja nicht um die frage ob
das impfen an sich sinnvoll ist
natürlich ist das impfen sinnvoll ich
bin selbstbewusst ich bin heilfroh dass
es gibt und wenn es weitere vorgaben
gibt
noch zu weiteren impfungen dann werde
ich die nutzen weil ich das einfach
sinnvoll finde nur die frage ist doch
können wir die menschen die schwer zu
erreichen sind tatsächlich mit einer
impfpflicht erreichen wenn
möglicherweise der staat gar nicht über
die infrastrukturellen voraussetzungen
verfügt die impfpflicht auch vernünftig
durchzusetzen ich meine wir dürfen doch
einige zweifel haben angesichts der auch
bekannten mängel bei der impfkampagne
bislang angesichts der bekannten menge
was die it strukturen angeht dass die
tatsächlichen voraussetzungen fehlt
wirklich gegeben sind wir sehen auch
allein schon die ganze debatte über den
aufbau des imf registers in österreich
ist das ein zentrales steuerungselement
die haben eine kombination von dell die
register und egal das ist doch dass die
elektronische gesundheitsakte das
funktioniert in österreich schon lange
das ist ja ja ja er ist also so lange
funktioniert sind in österreich noch
nicht also es gibt es jetzt noch nicht
jahrelang sondern das ist nein es ist
stück für stück ich glaube anfang 2020
ist es ja aber das ist das ist würde ich
sagen das ist aber schon eine jahrelange
aufbau und erfahrung ebenfalls deutlich
länger als in deutschland wo wir wissen
wo es ja ein bisschen gesagt jetzt knapp
das war jahre er wird aber das ist wie
es vielleicht sagte das ist nach nach
aufgebaut worden dann aber jetzt schon
seit einiger zeit auf einen vernünftigen
zustand das würde ich jetzt nicht mal
erst gestern nennen sondern wir haben
lange lange erfahrung ich finde das ist
ein wichtige wichtiges bauelement und
wir haben ja auch schon in deutschland
längere diskussionen über eine
patientenakte und ähnliches was ich
sagen will damit ist wer wäre eine
impfpflicht umsetzen will der sollte auf
die tatsächlichen bedingungen parat
haben und da habe ich eben zweifel das
erklärt vielleicht auch wenn das wird
sich im ergebnis keine
gewissensentscheidung ist dass ich
endlich wie ein müller das vielleicht an
unterschiedlichen stellen unbehagen gibt
tatsächlich so eine impfpflicht selbst
wenn man sich im grunde nach für
vernünftig hält bei gibt's ja man viele
die das so sehen ob man sich auch
wirklich realisieren kann und das muss
doch ein wichtiger punkt sein und
darüber muss eben geredet werden man
kann ja endlich jahren das ist ja gar
nicht der punkt sondern man muss dann
aber auch sagen wie wir umgesetzt und
man sollte das nicht so marginalisieren
nach dem motto ach das wird sich schon
ergeben oder das wird schon
funktionieren
manchmal habe ich den eindruck hofft man
darauf dass die füße angst entsteht die
leute wollen dann irgendwie vielleicht
nachteile vermeiden lassen sich dann
impfen das kann sagen ich kann das nicht
ausschließen aber ich habe ein bisschen
sorge wenn ich manche schwierigen und
auch wirklich verstörend entwicklungen
sicher bei den demonstrationen in
manchen teilen des landes ob das
wirklich so problemlos gehen wird ob
sich das dann schon irgendwie sozusagen
ergeben wird ohne dass es dann eine
durchsetzung probleme gibt hat er sich
diese tatsächlichen dinge nur den satz
noch die tatsächlichen seite der
impfpflicht dürfen wenn ich einfach an
die seite schieben das zentrale heißt
das für sie impfpflicht und impfung ist
es sind zwei seiten einer medaille
also ich irgendwas finde ich es
vernünftig wenn man weiß was man tut und
dass man alle register hat indem man
versucht menschen zu erreichen geordnet
anzuschreiben erinnerungsschreiben das
sind ja nicht gebaut und in der
österreichischen gesetz das heißt man
hat auch mal eine vorstellung davon was
man tut hier gibt es diskussionen
darüber jahr den berliner behörden ein
kommt man mal wieder besser das den
kontrollieren vielleicht die kommunen
vielleicht auch nicht also ich meine
dass wir haben doch überhaupt keine
klare vorstellung davon überhaupt das
umgesetzt werden sollte und ich nochmals
wir sehen ja und da ist österreich ein
vielfaches beispiel schöne übrigens auch
bei der elektronischen gesundheitsakte
dass die dinge über jahre vernünftig auf
den weg gebracht werden können dass man
die struktur aufbaut die funktionieren
wird es dann ernst wird das ist eine
ernste lage für ein land auch in unserem
land dann hat man kann man aufbauen kann
dann relativ kurzer zeit dafür sorgen
dass auch eine impfpflicht funktioniert
und das ist der kritikpunkt von uns
gewesen wir haben ganz klar gesagt
inflationiert beitrag es geht nicht um
eine sozusagen generelle skeptiker gegen
die impfung es geht nur darum verwendet
das nicht als symbol für irgendetwas für
handlungsfähigkeit sondern macht euch
klar das muss hinterlegt sein die
tatsächlichen voraussetzungen die das
effektiv machen und auch mit rechtlichen
ich glaube man darf sich nicht zu sehr
auf die querdenker die sogenannten
kaprizieren oder auf die spalte mögliche
spaltung der gesellschaft dass wir
glaube ich der falsche weg
das wäre ein einknicken vor dem
irrationalen und ich glaube auch eine
politische entscheidung die muss
durchdacht sein und klar sein aber ich
glaube nicht dass ihr
verfassungsrechtlich wenn der
gesetzgeber es nicht ganz dämlich
anstellt scheitern wird weil ich lese
schon aus der karlsruher rechtsprechung
heraus man muss das auch nicht im
einzelnen kommt ganz genau belegen weil
das eben auch in der unklaren
gefahrenlage mit denen sich mit der sich
kriens beschäftigt hat
intensiv beschäftigt dabei auch einmütig
dass der gesetzgeber da eben was
plausibles vorlegen muss und dann wird
karlsruhe nicht hingehen und sagen ihr
müsst aber ab 45 anfangen und dann
stufenweise und zwar wie folgt bei das
eben auch komisch aussehen würde jetzt
mal salopp gesagt auf
verfassungsrechtlich mehr würde ich das
heißt ein stimmiges konzept natürlich
wissenschaftlich fundiert aber da eben
auch mit einschätzungsspielraum und ich
glaube da ist eine auch eine allgemeine
impfpflicht machbar aber der gesetzgeber
oder die politik muss jetzt eben auch
farbe bekennen über verbale parolen
hinaus und würde für sie ein impf
register zur impfpflicht dazu gehören
herr müller ja irgendwie in der tat muss
man die leute würde ich auch sagen
zuerst vielleicht anschreiben es muss
jetzt nicht unbedingt eine zentralstelle
sein die alle daten verwaltet aber es
hat sich ja schon bei den impfung
gezeigt wo man die leute angeschrieben
hat die älteren zuerst aus niedersachsen
habe ich gehört dann ging man irgendwie
nach den namen und wollte aus denen aus
der art des vornamens das alter ablesen
weil es eben keine daten gab schon auf
landesebene teilweise und das ist
natürlich schwierig wenn man dann eben
noch anderes durchsetzen will das stimmt
ich glaube nicht dass man jetzt also es
müssen wir müsste möglich sein das zu
erfassen wir haben ja immerhin an die
200 millionen impfdosen schon verimpft
in gewisser weise anonymisiert aber es
müsste glaube ich möglich sein
vielleicht auch ohne zentrales register
eine impfpflicht durchzusetzen aber
natürlich muss dargestellt sein dass man
so der schon geimpft ist und wer noch
aufgefordert werden muss genau ich meine
da kommt das was sie auch schon eben
sagten es war natürlich zumindest
rückblickend ist das deutlicher als
seinerzeit es war ein fehler die
impfpflicht als eine option
auszuschließen das hat natürlich auch
zeit genommen infrastrukturell von sich
vorzubereiten also ich meine hätten dann
hätte jetzt die zeit nutzen können was
die idee fragen angeht was ein register
angeht muss jetzt nicht im register
genannt wird hätte er vielleicht andere
lösungen finden können und das ist
eigentlich das was sicher als muster
und das sage ich als jemand der das
insgesamt immer noch findet dass das
dass staat und verwaltung noch gut
hinbekommen aber trotzdem dürfen wir
darüber auch nicht die dinge aus dem
blick für den die nicht gut laufen und
das ist schon hätten muster dass
bestimmte dinge doch jedenfalls nach dem
ersten jahr der pandemie doch sich auf
drängten das gilt für den schulbereich
das gilt auch für das gesundheitswesen
das gilt für den it bereich und ist
nichts wirklich außer wie sie eben das
zu recht sagt was irgendwelche parolen
und ähnliches passiert und wir hatten zu
wenig dann auch versucht unter hohem
zeitdruck entsprechende strukturen
aufzubauen und wenn wir beispielsweise
die zeit genutzt hätten jetzt auch über
ein vernünftiges register wie man das
jetzt nennt im register oder anders die
menschen dann jetzt auch gut erreichen
zu können immer die zeit genutzt hätte
dann wäre vielleicht auch die debatte
über die umsetzbarkeit eine ganz andere
dann könnte man sagen das ist überhaupt
kein problem mehr erreichen die menschen
wir können haben eine vorstellung davon
wie wir sie tatsächlich auch ansprechen
usw und das ist alles wiederum mal
wieder nicht passiert und das macht mich
eben auch skeptisch ob wir jetzt aus dem
stand heraus selbst wenn wir so eine art
impfpflicht auf vorrat verabschieden die
dann vielleicht noch mal im herbst
kurzfristig noch mal modifiziert wird
wenn klarheit besteht über die
virusvarianten und die impfstoffe ob das
infrastrukturell vom tatsächlichen hier
auch wirklich gelingt es ist also
überhaupt nicht ein misstrauen gegenüber
dem staat und der verwaltung es geht mir
auch gar nicht wer den kann andere ich
glaube das lässt sich alles gut in den
griff kriegen ist geht mir schlichtweg
darum ist das das ziel dass eine
impfpflicht zu erreichen vorgibt
tatsächlich wirklich zu erreichen da
stehen sich so viele tatsächlich gehören
über die muss man sprechen muss ich auch
ehrlich dann machen und sagen kriegen
wir das bis zum herbst noch alles gut
geregelt kriegen wir das nicht gut
geregelt ja das haben wir versucht so
ein bisschen jetzt gemeinsam zu
ergründen welche hürden bis dahin noch
bestehen haben das aus zwei
unterschiedlichen perspektiven
beleuchtet einmal mit stephan rixen
professor für öffentliches recht sozial
wirtschafts und gesundheitsrecht an der
universität bayreuth
einer der vier mitglieder des ethikrates
die gegen eine ausgeweitete impfpflicht
votiert haben und mit reinhard müller
verantwortlicher redakteur für
zeitgeschehen bei der f für faz ein
spruch der sich in mehreren kommentaren
für eine impfpflicht ausgesprochen hat
wir haben festgestellt dass beide in den
details seien gar nicht so weit
auseinander liegen wie man das
vielleicht meinen könnte bei der analyse
der staatlichen aufgaben waren beide
ziemlich einig vielen dank an
professorin für das gespräch und auch
vielen dank reinhard müller vielen dank
kleiner finger gerissen
jetzt sind wir bei der rechtsgeschichte
klingt langweilig ist aber auch durchaus
relevant für prüfung und praxis was muss
man wissen zur impfpflicht pocken masern
europäischer gerichtshof für
menschenrechte erklären sie doch mal aus
seit wann das thema überhaupt ihr elend
ist ja das ist schon ziemlich lange
virulent viele denken ja das reichs impf
gesetz sei sozusagen die erste
impfpflicht in deutschland gewesen aber
das stimmt gar nicht die bayern waren
mal wieder schneller und zwar 1807 war
es so dass die erste im pflicht
überhaupt eingeführt wurde eben im
königreich bayern und zwar gegen die
pocken das war ja damals das große
problem und man hatte daneben entdeckt
dass man dafür eine impfung finden kann
und dann eben auch diese solche sich
effektiv bekämpfen lässt und deshalb war
damals eben dann vorgeschrieben alle
über dreijährigen die noch keine pocken
hatten müssen bis zu einem bestimmten
datum das war der erste siebter 1808
geimpft sein die impfung gab es nur
einmal das hat dann später auch noch zu
problemen geführt weil die eben nicht
ewig vor gehalten hat und und das finde
ich besonders spannend es gab eine
strafe für eltern die das nicht machen
die sich nach vermögen gestaffelt hat
das ist ja ganz interessant weil ja
heute gesagt wird wie wir das als
ordnungswidrigkeit fest schreiben dann
zahlt man eben und die reichen zahlen
vielleicht auch mehrmals manche sagen
auch sie sollen nicht dafür zur
ersatzfreiheitsstrafe link nast
einrücken und das hieße ja dann die
reichen können sich freikaufen die haben
müssen sich impfen lassen wenn man diese
historische vorbild sieht nach vermögen
könnte man ja sagen dieser weg ist
versperrt jedenfalls müssten dann die
reichen anteilig zahlen genauso war es
weil es war so dass ein handwerker
geselle damals etwa einen gulden pro tag
verdient hat und da merkt man bei acht
gulden wenn das bis zu acht gulden gegen
dann musste der acht tage dafür arbeiten
und damit ist es dann tatsächlich auch
ganz gut gelungen ebendieses pocken
problem in bayern in den griff zu
bekommen
nicht nur in bayern das ganze war ein
ziemlicher exportschlager bei solche
gesetze wurden dann auch eingeführt nach
und nach in baden württemberg 1821 in
hannover und 1826 dann in sachsen weimar
eisenach und einer der minister die da
übrigens darauf achten mussten dass das
gesetz auch umgesetzt wird war ein
gewisser johann wolfgang von goethe zu
dem wir hier ja in frankfurt auch ein
ganz besonderen bezug haben also ein
früher forcierte impfpflicht so könnte
man eine kaste dichter als im vollzugs
mensch absolut es gibt sogar briefe von
ihm wo er dann auch anmahnen das doch
bitte dieses gesetz auch mal umgesetzt
werde also wenn man das war es gibt 15
punkte wenn ein muss die letzten
körnchen fehlen dann bitte merken ich
hoffe dass herr müller ist dass alle
prüfer die uns jetzt zu hören genauso
sehen dann war das reicher seinerzeit
noch viel stärker verspätet und
deutschland noch viel stärker
zersplittert es kam dann irgendwann zur
einigung einige jahrzehnte später
deutschlands unter bismarck und es kam
zum reichs ins gesetz genau so ist es
und auslöser für das reichs im gesetz
war eigentlich der deutsch französische
krieg da war es nämlich so dass die
deutschen soldaten
eigentlich ganz gut durchgekämpft waren
gegen die pocken die französischen
soldaten aber nicht weil es eben da noch
keine soldaten bezogene impfpflicht gab
und das hatte zur folge dass dann sich
durch den krieg auch die pocken in der
deutschen bevölkerung immer weiter
verbreiteten einfach durch das
kriegsgeschehen und da hat man dann
gesagt naja da müssen wir was gegen tun
und
1874 gab es dann wirklich ein reiches im
gesetz für alle ist auch interessant
also wer wer lust hat so unter den nerds
unter den hörern die können das auch
gerne mal im inter jetzt sich angucken
das gibt es noch im reichs gesetzblatt
1874 seite 31 ford folgende kann man
frei im internet sich angucken der
aufbau dieses gesetzes ist auch ganz
spannend weil es da eben auch so
gestufte sanktionen gibt na also wenn
eltern keinen impfnachweis vorlegen
konnten dann mussten sie eine geldstrafe
bis zu 20 mark zahlen und wenn es dann
noch mal eine amtliche aufforderung gab
und sie immer noch nicht ihre kinder
haben impfen lassen dann ging es sogar
so weit dass dann bis zu 50 mark oder
auch eine haft von drei tagen in rhede
standen insgesamt wurde die impfung auch
ausgeweitet es war also einmal so dass
als säugling man geimpft werden musste
und dann ist der auffrischungsimpfung
gehabt noch mal zum zum zwölften
lebensjahr dieses reiches im gesetz ist
deshalb ebenso spannend weil es
tatsächlich unglaublich lange bestanden
hat also immer merkt natürlich dass die
probleme die uns heute beschäftigen
schon alle da waren im grunde absolut
also seine durchsetzung im funk von
gefangenen gefesselten ärzte weigern
sich also alle alle diskussionen die es
damals gab gibt es heute wieder übrigens
auch die sehr gut organisierten
impfgegner 1914 gab es im deutschen
reich 300.000 mitglieder in enns gegner
verein die hatten damals zwar noch keine
telegramm gruppe aber viele andere
möglichkeiten zu kommunizieren und auch
viele viele zeitschriften das hat denn
der parlamentarische rat später aus
diesen vorgängen aus dieser
vorgeschichte gefolgert der hat daraus
gefolgert dass eine impfpflicht
grundsätzlich erlaubt sein muss also das
war wenn man die protokolle des
parlamentarischen rates wiegands
einhellige meinung
und darauf hat sich dann auch der
bundesgerichtshof und das
bundesverwaltungsgericht gestützt die
haben in den 50er jahren sich auch mal
damit beschäftigt ist das eigentlich mit
dem grundgesetz vereinbar oder nicht und
haben dann eben auch diese beratung vom
parlamentarischen rat zu grunde gelegt
für ihre entscheidung ganz aktuell das
wird interessanterweise auch häufig
nicht mehr erwähnt ja auch die masern in
pflicht die sozusagen ja viel jüngeren
datums ist als die alte pop nicht wo ich
sagen könnte das war eine andere zeit
das war die nachkriegszeit oder der
gedanke dass der staat solche eingriff
in die körperliche unversehrtheit
durchsetzen kann es anders gewesen aber
auch die masern im pflicht ging ja
relativ glatt durch so ist es man muss
vorher noch sagen wie ging das
eigentlich mit der mit der pockenimpfung
zu ende da war es so dass
1975 die erste impfung für kleinkinder
aufgehoben wurde und
1980 dann die
weltgesundheitsorganisation verkündet
hatte wir haben die pocken besiegt und
drei jahre später dann das reich sims
gesetz eben komplett aufgehoben wurde
das heißt man konnte als es um die
masern dann ging
2018/2019 ging da die debatte los darauf
nicht zurückgreifen man brauchte also
eine völlig neue gesetzliche regelung
und die hat man eingebaut ins
infektionsschutzgesetz genauer in den
paragraph 20 absätze 8 bis 14 er wurde
ein ziemlich kompliziertes regelungs
konstrukt eingeführt das eben kita
besucher tagesmütter kinder die da
betreut werden schulkinder und auch
erzieher lehrer medizinisches personal
flüchtlinge in gemeinschaftsunterkünften
also ganz ganz viele verschiedene
gruppen dass die eben alle nachweise
einer masernimpfung vorlegen muss über
die lage beim ttc startschuss gab ich
habe es ganz interessant beim ethikrat
war es so dass der damals strikt gegen
eine impfpflicht argumentiert hat und
zwar mit dem ultima ratio argument
während in der politik ist eine sehr
sehr starke gruppe gab die das
befürwortet hat mit einzelnen ausnahmen
kai klose gesundheitsminister hier in
hessen der hat das nicht so gut gefunden
aber an sich gab es dafür eine große
mehrheit und man muss sagen dass dann
diese masern im pflicht auch ein
stückweit vorlage war für die
einrichtungs bezogene corona impfpflicht
ja noch mal von der allgemeinen corona
impfpflicht zu unterscheiden ist die
startet ja jetzt schon mitte märz
zurzeit wird noch heiß diskutiert wie
das dann mit dem vollzug sein soll
gesetzes systematisch muss man sagen
wurde es ähnlich aufgebaut wie bei der
ma sahen im pflicht wurde dann ein § 20a
ins infektionsschutzgesetz eingefügt
inhaltlich gibt es ein paar unterschiede
also im beispiel dass die kitas nicht
einbezogen werden das hatte die
unionsfraktion im bundestag gefordert
konnte sich damit aber nicht durchsetzen
ein anderer unterschied ist natürlich
auch ein wichtiger unterschied dass bei
der ma sahen im pflicht ja auch die
betreuten bzw untergebrachten personen
erfasst sind während das bei der
einrichtungs bezogenen corona
impfpflicht nicht der fall ist die
masern im pflicht war auch schon in
karlsruhe aber jedenfalls im
eilverfahren hat das verfassungsgericht
ja gesagt das ist in ordnung so wichtig
richtig und es gibt natürlich noch den
blick über die deutschen grenzen hinweg
auch ganz interessant auch straßburg der
europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte hat sich schon mit dem
thema impfpflicht befasst genau und zwar
im april 2021 aber völlig unabhängig vom
thema corona man könnte ja denken na ja
da ging es doch garantiert dann auch um
corona bei der die pandemie ja schon
voll im gange war das ist aber gar nicht
der fall es ging um routine impfungen in
tschechien zum beispiel gegen hepatitis
b tetanus das ist da alles
vorgeschrieben zumindest für
kindergartenkinder und dagegen wurde
eben auch geklagt und wurde gesagt naja
ist ja nicht möglicherweise das recht
auf achtung des privatlebens oder der
gewissensfreiheit oder das recht auf
bildung aus der europäischen
menschenrechtskonvention
verletzt und da hat das gericht gesagt
nee das ist nicht der fall übrigens mit
einer ähnlichen argumentation wie das
bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt zur
bundes notbremse herangezogen hat die
haben nämlich einfach gesagt das ist
sache der politik die haben da einen
großen abwägung spielraum und den hatte
hier die tschechische regierung eben
auch wunderbar ja man sieht natürlich
daran auch in der tat ähnlich über der
politik es gibt ein
einschätzungsspielraum und der er sagt
ja auch oft ihr habt als mitgliedstaaten
auch einen spielraum wie ihr grundrecht
auslebt gewissermaßen auch wie sie
ablegt es gibt gewisse grenzen die
straßburg setzt und das hat es eben
schon dass hier keine gesetzt wurde
[Musik]
ja jetzt kommen wir zu dem teil auf
denen sich viele schon gefreut haben
nämlich zu dem gespräch mit greser &
lenz den karikaturisten der faz hallo
herr gräser hallo herr lenz das wird das
wird ja schöne grüße auch von mir nach
aschaffenburg irgendwie schön die
diaspora sozusagen obwohl das du die
astoria
genauer aus dem vorgezogene beobachter
und kampf posten schon im bayernland was
sind das eigentlich für zeiten jetzt man
sagt er eigentlich die krise ist eine
gute zeit für die kunst stimmt dass so
ein
thema zu bekommen
gesundheit tun zu lassen
haben wir schon motiviert vor allen
dingen die bei denen es um die wurst
geht letztlich um sieht man tot ist
natürlich auch die die also die die
komische arbeit daran dass also aufs
korn das komische aus daraus zu melden
existieren
krisenzeiten tragen köhler und
angenehmer und hat man es auch gemerkt
an den reaktionen dass es etwas
besonderes dass ich mein corona ist ja
eine andere krise als mal wegen die
ukraine krise auch wenn die auch noch
sich zu einem heißen krieg entwickeln
kann aber das ist weit weg könnte man
sagen oder der golfkrieg oder selbst
irgendwelche konflikte mit erdogan hier
ist es ja so wie du schon gesagt hast
achim jeder ist persönlich potenziell
betroffen ist das noch mal ein anderes
ding auch was so die nachfrage nach
kunst oder die reaktion auf eure
zeichnung angeht
also ist nicht mehr so wir haben
allgemein so artmann position gegen das
sagen die sonst üblicherweise natürlich
passiert nichts wird keinen platz finden
und haben das etikett dass das komisch
ist dann und dass das ist glaube ich
wohl das ist wohl tun das gefällt den
leuten und das hat da ist das sozial
hygienische oder gehabt persönlichkeit
hygienische funktion aber das ist jetzt
nicht mehr oder weniger als in
mir ist so ein bisschen aufgefallen ich
habe mir man park karikaturen diese so
zum thema impfpflicht gezeichnet haben
angeguckt dass sie sehr oft die
impfgegner
darstellen und die auch sehr sehr lustig
darstellen eignen sich ins gegner
irgendwie besonders gut für karikaturen
ist natürlich ein glücksfall der
menschen gemeldet haben
alles jeden bären aufbinden lassen
und das ist deswegen
große angst gehabt die wir halt dann
gewendet haben
dass er während er ist ja dass das ja
dass das was die anbieten an botschaften
ja eigentlich auch von der tollen toren
das sind und eigentlich ein kollektives
kopfschütteln und lachen hervor rufen
müssten tut sich also es ist erstaunlich
dass die dass das dass das nicht nur ein
banaler comic figuren sind sondern dass
die sehr ernst genommen werden und dass
man sich tatsächlich dann auch immer
wieder vor kurzem muss als komische
figuren und gibt es in dieser in dieser
impfpflicht debatte auch politiker die
sich besonders gut für karikaturen
eignen
sagen jaja dazu darauf zu verzichten auf
die auf das abbild
der politiker aus der ersten reihe
ich habe aber so einen gesehen der haben
sie irgendwie den nikolaus gemalt und
daneben war irgendwie karl lauterbach
als knecht ruprecht ja das hat ja die
mutter die das ihrem kind erklärt hat
das phänomen das 6 dezember nikolaus
unterwegs ist ein gutmütiger mit einem
bösartigen
haben denn so erklärt ja ist es auch
eure erfahrung weil du schon sagtest
eigentlich das teilweise komische
figuren oder eigentlich vertrauen auch
kluge leute irgendwelchen eigentlicher
witzigen köpfen die aber nicht recht
glaubhaft sind
nett ist das auch eure erfahrungen so
aus dem privaten umfeld dass man sich
plötzlich wundert was für ansichten
geäußert werden ich habe den
karteikarten meiner bekannten und
freunde etwas lüften müssen
ziemlich überrascht habe
möglich also den meisten ist das milieu
nehmen wir uns jetzt natürlich auch um
greifen diesen treiben zum
dämmerschoppen
das sind so menschen die die
vermutlichen lebenslang alkoholkonsum
große lebens sorgen
nicht im vordergrund steht auch nicht
jetzt angesichts der bei dem wieder gab
es wenig gelegen waren davon betroffen
wir wollen das jetzt der weg vom
biertisch
unverändert wieder
ich kein großes thema ich bin auch immer
wieder überrascht dass so was ist es
kann auch sein dass ist so vielleicht an
diesem
offiziellen kleinstädtischen million
liegt es dass das das dass man versucht
das thema zu banden weil man insgeheim
eine furchtbare angst davor hat und das
bildungs nicht zur sprache bringen will
um himmels willen weil irgendwelche
aberglaubens reflexe da noch wirksam
sind und die dafür sorgen dass bei der
besten überhaupt darüber spricht und das
thema pflicht ist ja wahrscheinlich auch
nicht nur in der kneipe sondern auch für
künstler ein reizthema wenn man die
absolute freiheit und satire darf alles
dagegen setzt aber wie verhält sich das
mit der impfpflicht gegner ist ja gesagt
potenziell oder war schmal tatsächlich
betroffen gibt das dem ganzen noch eine
besondere note diese diskussion jetzt
über pflicht freiheit solidarität
ja wir haben den wunsch oder die die
perspektive dass die gesellschaft erst
zufrieden gestellt ist wenn eine totale
freiheit besagt ist ausgerufen wird das
heißt auch dass die pflicht sich im
straßenverkehr die rechtsverordnung dazu
halten aufgegeben wird das begrüße ich
auch sehr das würde dann vermutlich zu
allerlei stockungen im verkehrsfluss
führen aber die die begegnungen von
wutbürgern die sich gegenseitig ihr
gedenken im auto vorwerfen durchaus auch
komische qualität nicht ich glaube da
du ich ein bisschen entspannter drauf
gucken weil ich jetzt tatsächlich als
ich hier nach frankfurt gezogen bin mein
auto abgeschafft habe aber so ganz egal
wäre es mir wahrscheinlich auch nicht
ich hätte noch einen anderen punkt mich
würde mal interessieren wie lange
eigentlich so dieses thema corona in den
karikaturen generell eine rolle gespielt
hat also es war ja irgendwie so dass
diese pandemie so ein bisschen
schleichend kann wenn man jetzt mal zwei
jahre zurück guckt man hat noch fröhlich
karneval gefeiert und plötzlich war das
virus da wissen sie noch wie das wahl
wann haben sie sich angefangen damit zu
beschäftigen
wie können wir das zeichnen und
es wurde auch haben wir jetzt viel auch
gewünschte reaktion dass wir vielleicht
etwas aufhellen es gibt mittlerweile so
eine möglichkeit das ist jetzt wirklich
auch langsam lagen wir haben auch
wirklich das gefühl und das noch
nachtragen das eigentlich gar kein
wunsch will ich das von der
vom bundestag haus sowie darüber geredet
türkische fast für die booster haft
wieder darüber seit monaten geregelt
würden obwohl ich noch dass wir werden
eingeführt wird jetzt mittlerweile
technisch ist die gewann steht vor
sowieso nicht vorbei geräten ist nun die
verhandlung noch so lange bis nur fahren
kann hat gute
spieler sind ja unser erster wird zum
thema hat übrigens noch in china
gespielt es war zu sehen weil da ein
chor kinderchor das thema war 2 100 bis
200 der geburts davon wird sich van
beethoven und die chinesen haben
gesungen
und freude schöner götterfunken die lage
mit schema um wenn man chinesen zu
sprechen bringen will mit und hatten
bersch und alle masken auf was natürlich
für den winzigen menschen
unmöglich ist das den vorgang unmöglich
macht also das als noch der begriff
pandemie also eine globale verbreitung
da noch weit entfernt war das ist noch
so als ferner kleines problem eines
einzelnen landes dar
und habt ihr genau weil ja schon sehr
hellsichtig aber anfang watt und etwas
voraus gesehen habe was dann eintritt
wird die idee was das ganze mit uns
langfristig macht also irgendwann wird
es ja doch was die schärfsten
beschränkung angeht mittelfristig wann
auch immer vorbei sein auch für das
virus bleiben wird macht das was mit uns
jetzt vielleicht über sachen die hände
schütteln ist ein bisschen aus der mode
gekommen massen aufsetzen es in die mode
gekommen aber wird das irgendwas
vielleicht auch was diese spaltung
angeht oder der will glaube wird dass
irgendwas nachhaltiges positiv oder
negativ hinterlassen wir haben schon
lange den eindruck dass die die debatte
die in der
die in der infrastrukturpolitik der
angelegt ist zu sagen dass bei uns so
vieles mal rote ist die brücken marode
sind die straßen schlagen wir haben dass
da ein erheblicher sanierungsbedarf ist
und viel geld viel steuergeld in die
hand genommen werden muss um das zu
beseitigen
unser vorschlag ist nicht nur daran zu
denken an die sanierung dessen was ist
sondern mehr irgendein staaten
einzurichten auch weil der bedarf danach
größer werden wird
und um zu verhindern das ist wirklich
schade konflikt in dieser
gesellschaftlichen
möglicherweise mehr truppen
in betreuung gebracht werden in
geschlossener gab es noch irgendein
wunsch der gezeichnet aber
unveröffentlicht blieb ja
wenn man bedenkt dass man statt der ems
liegt vielleicht nochmals größere werben
der anstrengung machen könnte um die
letzten verweigere
zur impfung zu bewegen dann müsste man
ja denken dann müsste man vielleicht den
helden ins blickfeld richten und zum
beispiel für die esoteriker sagen dass
die butter hat sich ohne weiteres hätte
impfen lassen oder die hildegard von
bingen hat sich bewusst und lassen mit
einer kräuter tinktur oder was auch
immer und eben auch die kameraden von
der rechten von der rechtsaußen front
die sind vielleicht auch zu begeistern
mit einem werbenden spruch der heißt ein
volk ein reich eine impfung oder rechter
truce arm hoch für die impfung hätte
sich auch impfen lassen die kampagne
muss dann auch gezogen werden von der
politik nichts mehr hilft ja ja ich bin
gern bereit
der grafische offene fragen gibt und wir
helfen können ganz herzlich dankbar
sehen wie es aufgegriffen wird ganz
herzlichen dank achim greser und
heribert lenz vielen dank auch von mir
nach aschaffenburg john keys danke
[Musik]
und damit sind wir jetzt auch am ende
unserer sonderfolge zu impfpflicht
angelangt war zugleich auch meine erste
podcast folge hierbei faz einspruch mir
hat es riesigen spaß gemacht ja herr
müller was haben wir noch im blick ja
ich fand es auch eine sehr gute
ergänzung sozusagen ein special agents
gut die reihe die ja von corinna bruders
und helene bobrowski sehr erfolgreich
gestaltet wird ganz herzlich danke fürs
zuhören hören sie weiter rein lesen sie
weiter mit und melden sich auch gern mit
anregungen und kritik und das können sie
tun bei der e mailadresse einspruch
podcast faz.de wo wir uns natürlich über
anregungen sehr sehr freuen und ja gerne
auch vorschläge für weitere
sondersendungen entgegen nehmen dann
allen ein schönes wochenende und bleiben
sie einspruch treu
auch von mir ein schönes wochenende bis
bald
[Musik]